well hello and hallelujah it's me
shangela hi everyone my name is bob the
dragon one of the hosts of we're here on
hbo and i'm here with buzzfeed for
burning questions oh they're hot these
questions are hot
how are you approached for we're here
and did you know that there would be
other drag queens involved i was
actually called by stephen warren and
johnny ingram the show creators and i
remember this specifically because i was
at opening night of the ariana grande
sweetener tour in albany new york i was
backstage with my friend frankie and we
were about to see ariana and say oh my
god you are fabulous and right when she
comes out my phone rings and it's steven
warren and he had text me earlier like
i'm gonna call he's very important i'm
like oh my god i'm so sorry i love you
hold on one second and i remember
answering the phone and being like yes
and he's giving me the whole spiel about
the show and honestly i probably would
have agreed to anything because i was
like yes of course sounds lovely baby
ariana i gotta go baby i gotta go i have
pictures in black and white from that
night because it was just so amazing oh
this is it can you see it
did i know that there were gonna be
other drag queens involved
maybe he said it on the phone but
honestly i was so excited to go tell
ariana she had killed it in the show
that i don't even remember but i do
remember when they first invited us to
their home to pitch us the show i saw
bob and eureka and i was just thrilled i
already knew them from drag race and to
be able to work with them in this
capacity it just made sense because the
show is about going to small
conservative towns across america i grew
up in a small conservative town in
america so i was like baby let's do it i
was approached by steven warren who's uh
one of the creators that we're here and
he was like i have an idea for a show
but i can't tell you over the phone i
need you to come to meet me at this
hotel in this restaurant and we'll chat
and then he pictured me and i absolutely
loved it well stephen warren calls me
and he's like hey is this eureka and i'm
like yes this is eureka and he's like
listen huge fan i want to meet you for
lunch i've got a show idea and the
craziest thing is when i was going in i
actually ran into zachary quinto whom is
my drag daughter from a them makeup
thing that i did where i put zachary and
drag as no offense so when i ran into
him i met with steve and johnny but then
when i was leaving i had a text from
zachary saying you know whatever the
idea is for the show
do it stephen warren's the greatest guy
to be in contact with in the industry
well so i kind of have that reassurance
i was like okay well i guess i'm doing
it i was immediately obsessed with the
idea of it being bob and shangela
because i knew of who they were what
they could bring to the table for me it
was like bob the drag queen is like such
an activist and has this way with a
political culture and being in the know
and in the now but also being a beloved
queen from the franchise and then
shangela being such a resourceful queen
business professional never knowing a
stranger so good at communication it
just made sense for her as well to me
and then obviously i was
the best for the job as far as who i am
at least in my eyes because i was
excited about this idea of what the show
was that's the team we're here as a lot
of emotional moments was there a moment
you filmed that you had to stop filming
because you were crying too much in one
of the towns we were there for the 4th
of july i actually kind of like ran away
from the cameras before they could film
me and i was watching these fireworks on
the 4th of july and i was having like a
really emotional response to celebrating
the 4th of july in this town as a
marginalized person and i was thinking
about like indigenous people and what it
means to be an american and who has
rights here and who doesn't have rights
here and missing people and in the
moment it really overwhelmed me and i i
literally just like ran from the camera
in full drag
it was it was actually really wild
honestly not the biggest crier on the
show i think the crier people goes from
like eureka cries the most bob is a
close second and then there's me i mean
i do get very emotional and attached but
i've just never been a big crying person
i've been more like okay let's figure
out the solution let's just get through
this was there ever a moment they had to
stop because i was crying no but maybe
because i was shedding tears and i
didn't want it going through my makeup
so i was like can we stop real quick so
i can just touch up please there are so
many emotional moments on this show that
would make anybody cry there's gonna be
laughs it's gonna be fun but baby bring
the kleenex i am a crier i'm an
emotional person there's probably been a
couple moments where i was very
emotional one specifically
was farmington new mexico with a dj whom
was the sibling that had committed
suicide and their family jocelyn and
jasmine it was just so sweet but also so
emotional and sad like i did have to
kind of step away and and have a few
moments at different moments like that
was probably the hardest emotionally on
me was that story for sure next question
we're here deals a lot with the topic of
living your life as your true authentic
self what advice or words of
encouragement would you give to someone
who is struggling with coming out or
with their gender identity you know as
you're figuring out who you are just
continue to love yourself through the
process and don't be afraid of owning
and loving all the parts of who you are
because they actually are very beautiful
you know my words of encouragement for
people that are coming out or gender
identity either one is kind of similar
because it's like to me i say
give me a fa take the time that you need
write uh the stipulations of society and
other people's expectations do not
matter it's about your comfort and that
goes along with like when that goes
along with how you come out or how you
identify make sure that you're ready and
that you have people that you love and
that you know love you and return around
you you owe no one any answers or
absolutes it is okay to explore gender
identity you don't have to be beholden
to what you said last year last week or
a minute ago as you discover new things
about yourself feel free to update
people and that is your business to tell
people you don't have to tell anyone
anything you don't want to tell them
it's about being comfortable with
yourself and making sure that you feel
comfortable around other people so just
know that your journey is yours you
don't have to follow a blueprint you
have to do what feels good for you of
the three of you
who is the biggest diva
and who takes the longest to get ready
that is changela counts boots down kitty
mama okay shangela is such a diva but in
like a loving beautiful way
and she takes the longest to get ready
period angela's the biggest diva and she
takes the longest to get ready
that is a quick and easy answer
shannon's the biggest divas she takes
the longest to get ready hands down
without a shadow of a doubt this is not
even up for debate okay if those girls
say me you make sure you circle back to
me and let me know okay cause a lot of
times they will say me i feel like
they're gonna say me but it is not me
what is a diva honestly if it's someone
who is committed to putting their best
foot forward at most if not at all times
then most definitely i can be considered
a diva i mean beyonce said a diva is the
female version of a hustla and i'm truly
a hustler ask any of my dread kids as
any of the people i work with shinji
comes to work okay so if that's a diva
that might be me who takes the longest
to get ready it used to be me but then
when it was me i started like making a
big effort to be first if i'm first i go
down with a belt and i'm ringing it
outside let it be known
shanji was here first hallelu i'm glad
she's working on it it's a work in
progress but uh it's not done mary if
you could bring a fellow brew girl to be
a special guest star on an episode of
we're here who would it be and why you
know i think someone like ginger man or
nina west someone like that who has like
very much um the emotional capacity
would be fun i also think it'd be
interesting to bring people with
cultural difference like i would love to
see like jackie cox maybe be a special
guest for someone that's muslim so
basically a queen of difference be there
to be kind of a coach to someone that's
had a similar lifestyle to them that'd
be cool you know moana exchanges is my
best friend and one of my favorite drag
queens of all time i just love spending
time with her and i think that she has a
really she's really remarkable has a
really great message being from lucia
and um from new york city she has a lot
of experience to pull from for a lot of
uh non-binary queer black people and
queer people in general it has to be my
drag mother alyssa edwards not only is
she a texan like me and has a big heart
and she's also a show girl we love a
good show and she knows what it's like
to be a coach and a positive spirit and
motivating spirit in someone's life so
if we ever have a mothers and daughters
episode trust the duchess honey you
might see me in a lesson together what's
the one challenge on drag race or
all-stars that you wish you could go
back and redo
well i think i did them all for uh
all-stars i think we had a redemption i
won that episode if there was anything i
could go back and re-do
definitely wouldn't be any of the sewing
challenges i would love to go back and
redo my snatch game in season three of
drag race i love tina turner okay i love
me some tina turner in season three of
drag race i did tina for the smash game
but for some reason i felt like my
nostrils looked smaller on tv so i
wanted to increase them with black
shadow so i did that thinking that was
tina turner and i just kept going
hallelujah hallelujah and i love tina i
know so i can sing simply the best right
now i could give you t i watched what's
love got to do with it 45 times i lived
in jennifer lewis's basement who played
tina turner's mama if i can't give you
tina turn at this point and win baby
just pack me up back to the house come
on if i come out the back
that's tina that's tina so probably
season 10 the pharma rusical i was in
such a weird place where i was in my
head just terrified to go home that i
like it caused me to mess up i wish i
could have went back and gotten myself
out of those nerves that's the one that
almost sent me home episode 2 of season
10. thank god oh kalorie kardashian
didn't stand a chance against these
lip-sync chops i don't think that i have
any re-do i really did a good job and i
won
and that's not me being egotistical but
like i i genuinely couldn't ask for a
better outcome
you know what i mean like everything
really worked out for me so
i would say that i wouldn't redo
anything there was some challenge where
i wasn't my best but it ended up working
out for me you know so my next question
is is it hard for you to go back and
watch the younger version of yourself
compete on your original season
season of drag race hell yeah
it's cringy you know because you just
you see how young you are and silly you
know what i mean and the things like you
can see the gears turning in your head
and the things that you were worried
about that aren't really necessary to
worry about the more mature and the
older you get i mean i first got on drag
race when i was 25 years old and i'm 31
now so it's six years ago and it's just
crazy how much you grow in six years
especially with this amount of fame and
exposure so it's like a little baby
eureka out there and she's super country
and she's just hi y'all
it's something else for sure no it is
not hard i always do it with uh
basically a warning label for anyone
who's watching it with me like okay
y'all already know that i'll look like
this no more right so don't be trying to
give me tips and stuff right based on
this right here because baby i don't
look i don't do that no more when i see
myself back then i'm like oh look a
little baby shinji oh lord
so it's not hard to watch but sometimes
i do put my head down over here she
comes here she goes cause you couldn't
tell me i wasn't winning delusion the
delusion of drag was very much in full
effect even all stars 3 even though i
didn't love the way that it ended
obviously i can still watch the season
because it was a victory lap for me in a
way it had been seven years since i've
been on the show i knew that i had grown
and evolved i have now seven years
experience of being a queen and putting
things together myself even though i
still couldn't so it just was cool to to
go in there and be like i want to win
but even if i don't win i want to be
able to showcase who i am today so come
on change let's put our best foot
forward and i felt confident in doing
that because i knew that i could no i i
thought i did great
i did a really good job i think that if
i didn't win i'd probably have a
different story i wasn't particularly
great at makeup or anything back then
but i stand by a lot of what i did on
that show i think i looked great i think
that i was funny i think that was
charming i was myself i don't feel like
i was being phonies i'm really i'm
really proud of the work i do on this
show all right you guys thank you so
much for having me on buzzfeed for
burning questions make sure that you
tune in to we're here now streaming on
hbo max it's fabulous so come out
and watch we're here you know what you
want to do if you want to tell your mom
you're gay just turn over here she'll
know like you'll be watching you'll be
like
that's me
i'm just like them
and then you'll bond then you'll cry
[Music]